the Joe Rogan experience what do you
think of 5g and all that scared
terrified all that [ __ ] yeah because
there's how much long-term testing have
they done in the zero or negative
numbers little off they're putting amok
dude is that would when when when I'm
driving around with my family my wife is
obsessed with recognizing plates she's
always calling at Florida Oregon she's
her and my son
they got a little game they play they're
always looking at the plates I'm always
looking at cell phone towers and
satellite dishes yeah all satellite
dishes point to the southeast for some
reason or other and that's what I always
check they don't pick point to the north
in Southern California that's just
DirecTV satellite that's all satellites
but every dish it's pointing to the sow
consumer consumer cellphone every
satellite dish that I've seen I am
obsessed with and they're always point
they never point to the north they're
always pointing south east all of them
the great majority of satellite dishes
that you see are probably Direct TV or
notice all of them all of them but you
go up it's it's crazy I don't know why I
don't know why but also those cell phone
towers I was on this website called um
smart meters murder dot-com smart meters
murder I was trying to remember it smart
meters murder calm dude you want to get
your [ __ ] head blown off go to that
website and read the documents that
they're pulling from different agencies
dude scary what you're talking about
scary ah but we is taking in stuff you
know what you're gonna have to go check
that [ __ ] but it's like on 5g but back
from back from their documents from
government agencies right from 2001 July
2001 it's like this whole I don't know
how big like 400 page plan for the world
it's a plan for the world are talking
about who wrote this plan the way you're
holding that yeah why you do it
it is quite hilarious it's the perfect
like if someone was talking about a
conspiracy theory and they had a blunt
and they were just like in the full-bore
conspiracy yeah while they're holding
the joint it's so scary dude that I
don't want to talk about it let's change
the subject you know if you want to look
into it go to SmartMeters dot-com smart
meters murder calm but it's scary I have
read I want to talk about it I have read
things where people are questioning the
like whether or not 5g is going to be
healthy but I haven't seen anything that
verifies it is or it isn't I haven't
seen anything that says yes I need to
look into it but but just in the what
I'm worried all told is that I really
think that Wi-Fi signals all the various
signals that surround us all the time I
think they have an effect on us and I
don't know what that effect is I don't
know if it's negative or positive I
don't know if it didn't it dulls the
senses it's entirely possible that it
does something to dull the senses
because it occupies an area I mean if we
have the capability of recognizing the
fact that there the theory signals
around us all the time cellular signors
signals radio signals satellite signals
we're surrounded constantly by signals
are we absolutely sure that our body
doesn't have the capacity to recognize
those signals even though we don't have
like a really clear method of taking
those signals in and then translating
them into visuals or into audio but
because we can't like take that Sirius
satellite signal and then and then have
like a player in our head because of
that we assume that we're not taking it
in in some way that's what these that's
what this report or let me just amazed
about it's about Bay this is why I say
this is why says because when I feel the
the least foggy is when I'm in the woods
when I'm in the mountains when there's
no cell phone service there's no radio
service there's no Wi-Fi there ain't
[ __ ] that's how satellites don't work
when someone's in the woods but no
satellites do work you could actually
not in the would show no in the bush you
get a dish you put on the roof of your
car you could watch tea that's a new
thing that Steve Rinella don't lawns
work on satellites no phones work on
cell towers put the GPS works on
satellites okay so your phone still
works as a GPS unit when you're in the
woods even if you don't in every signal
so so you can find your way out with a
map if your phone was on you know
there's people that say the GSP the GPS
GSP the GPS is also run by the towers -
they don't need to go into space that
you could triangulate your position from
towers alone but that's what you
probably could try to triangulate your
position from towers but you couldn't
broadcast a such a gigantic area like
you can with satellites you can see
satellites the people that think that
satellites aren't real they need to talk
to someone who make satellites they were
there you can see them with telescopes
they're up there we have the ability to
tune in to the very specific spot in the
sky with a direct tv and you'll pick up
the signal that's how you get the signal
you tuned to spot in the sky with the
satellite is and you pick up the signal
they're real people have a problem with
[ __ ] everything that's ever existed
everything everything's fake
everything's fake people think most of
it is
[Applause]